we are joined now by darius leonard
darius
all pro man what a performance by you
tonight the turnover king we called you
in the pre-game show this was some slop
out here on this field what was it like
actually playing in it it was terrible
just trying to move around especially
playing against this offense they're
with a lot of misdirection runs and
stuff like that so it was tough trying
to get your feet but um you know when we
knew that the ball would be able to come
off
come off a guy so just make sure that we
punch out the ball
every time we get and luckily we got
that in the second quarter to get the
momentum switch and weather like this
are are you doing anything different
with your shoes are you putting in
longer cliques are you doing anything
special to your body to make sure that
you don't slip and slide out there oh no
man i'm superstitious you know i like
that
i like to wear what i wear man um i feel
comfortable in the cleats that i
practice in so when i go out and play
you know i'm wearing them same things
and i'm just running around just trying
to make plays i talked to you earlier
this week and you talk to me about the
punch and to be able to see that in
person i want you to i want you to just
tell me what what are you looking at oh
man it's easy um you know i'm coming
from the right side i'm right hand
dominant and he got long sleeves on in
the ring the ball in his right hand and
you know that's that's trouble so i'm
coming in i seen the way he was carrying
it he was faced up on kenny never saw me
coming i saw the fat of the ball and
just punched it up one of the things
that i was most impressed with you about
is just you know your level of
preparation you know you talk about
studying the receipt
the running backs how high they carry
the ball how low they carry the ball if
they carry it loose talk about your
preparation because people see the end
result but they don't know the type of
work that you put in um yeah so the
first thing i do whenever like when i
get on the plane or whatever i'm
watching i'm gonna watch the opponent
i'm gonna see where they top runs top
passes their formations and then after i
feel like i got a comfortable
comfortable read of what they do
now i'm studying runners you know i need
to know their fumble history i need to
know what the what ball they love to
create their hands i'm gonna carry the
ball in because a lot of people don't
teach them body ball boundary put the
ball on the outside so you know i'm
trying to watch over that and then
seeing when guys go through traffic how
are they carrying the ball if they're
going to try to put four points of
pressure on it or not so my eyes are
automatically 24 7 on the ball so every
chance i get you know trying to get a
good clean punch out on it you guys have
won three of the last four now carson
wins trying to put together this second
chapter if you will of his career in
indianapolis how has he impacted this
locker room man he impacted a lot man
and you know i'm loving everything that
he's doing you know he's been a great
leader great teammate and he's doing a
great job by shutting the damn daughters
up you don't think he's doing anybody
get talking trash about who he is and
you know what he did in philly but
people got to understand that you know
this is the next chapter in his life and
he's stepping up in every big every way
that he possibly can and i just pray
that he continue to get better continue
to lead his offense obviously quentin
nelson he's not a hundred percent but
just talk to us about how important it
is to have him back on the field
especially with that running back that
you got back there i mean whenever cue
nelly out there man you know that's
always great for our offense and you
know they're going to run the ball
behind them and you're going to make
sure that he's helping everybody out
whenever he gets a chance in the pass
game so that's one thing about q man
he's a nasty guy you know he want to get
down he want to get dirty so when having
him back man that's that's that
mentality that mean mentality that we
need on office line i got to ask you
this because it just popped in my mind
when i was out there right there
watching xavier rhodes warm up the dude
was limping
he was limping and he still went out
there he fought and clawed came up with
a key interception man that was big um
because um like you said in warm-ups
like he said he did one thing in
warm-ups and then aggravated his calf
and so he went right into the locker
room so he was kind of scared to see if
he was going to play or not but he
stepped up big whenever we needed to so
that's one thing about having a veteran
cornerback in this league you know he's
been great for us so that play was very
big to get us off the field get the
offense back run some time off the clock
and we scored there so that was
definitely a great big play by him well
we've been traveling around all fall we
did do these post-game interviews
electric we've seen some unbelievable
chains that's got to be the coolest
chain we've seen the entire year talk me
through the process behind this one hey
man you got to be rich
i got to give it to my wife i went i
went home i went home friday yeah she
said i got a surprise for you she said
all the hard work that you've done you
know everything that you do in the game
you you're always focused you're always
weird by somebody else and she just
wanted to kind of show a little token of
her love for me so you know i just got
to thank my baby for this one that's
awesome and your daughter too i heard
you've been dancing with her a little
bit we even got the video right here yes
sir man you know my daughter's a mean to
me uh well especially my oldest one
she she's got a minnie mouse because
she's a better dancer that's true that
is true she's like she's a goofball man
i love it so i was blessed with two
beautiful little girls and my oldest one
man she got a great personality man i
just enjoy every bit of it you know
after a win or after a loss and coming
home to them is by far the best thing in
my life that i possibly could have come
on to isn't it nice coming home to your
daughters and you know with sons they'd
be like what's up dude
with daughters they come up they jump
they hug you i don't care what age they
are that's really nice to me it's
amazing because when i come home i'm
hurting you know the first day my
daughter said daddy what's wrong are you
okay
and she makes sure that she makes sure
that you know i'm sitting down and
taking care of myself so it's great to
have two little girls man
how sweet is this flight back cross
country
oh man i can't wait to get back on this
flight man it was it was a long flight
coming in but you know it's going to be
quick going back because we're going to
have a great time on the plane baby amen
to that darius really appreciate you
taking some time congratulations on the
win tonight thank you great meeting you
spending some time with you yes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports